okay then guys we are gonna pick up where we left off
with 2023
you
okay
so
we are in month of april
we are
bearish
we're in a huge price like but the good thing is this is the best part of the
this is the best part of the price like to be shorting for example if this does
trade
into this target this is the best price like to be short as opposed to this
price like
all right
okay let's move this so it's third of april monday
let's have a look what we have today we have ism at 10 can do with that um
there we are bearish
should be sure there's nothing in there about us and there is
nope
that would be nice
nah i don't think so
i think so i think that does break it right
maybe not
ism at 10
whoa okay we're building up
a lot of liquidity and bicep
(silence)
Now, the likelihood that this entire trade runs to this target is probably
pretty slim.
Let me make sure there's no news before we execute.
Tuesday 4th of April, we do have news.
But not right now.
And, boudom.
(silence)
A shift, bullish.
Nope.
(silence)
We have...
New York.
(silence)
We're about to have news.
We'll see how this one plays out because we do have...
There's a tag.
We're about to get news in the next 50 minute candle.
I don't want to hold through a news.
So, for this specific example, I'm going to move stops to break even.
But, if you're in the live market, I don't know how to even say you don't get
into the trade.
Or, if you're obviously going to get into trade, then be aggressive with
management or be closing it before the news comes out.
Unless, for example, if you're up here, maybe you can get over it.
It's going to be dependent on the context, like I said many times, but...
And that's just next to what we get.
As you can see...
That'll be... go down and break even.
Honestly...
Probably just go down. It's not even taking it.
It's having a classic shift to bearish, which I really like.
Here's what it is.
It's difficult when it's...
When there's just a bunch of mitigations in place, and the rest of the reward
ers feel like something like that is particularly small.
Everything is mitigated on all time frames.
Literally, everything is mitigated.
There's no other interest. The only area of interest is there is a one to two.
So, I would, in this case, just sit out my hands pretty much.
I wouldn't have tagged it anyway.
We are looking for shorts, still.
I don't even check on this.
First day six with April, so maybe ADP, probably.
But there's no news in...
There's no news in trade of view, which is what I'm using.
There's no news in trade of view.
It's a very weak break, as well, to be honest.
Still bearish. There's a lot of liquidity in this region, though.
Friday 7th April, that would be NFP.
Nothing for...
Nothing for our session.
Can we get an entry? Nope.
Okay.
Still doesn't give a continuation.
So, still technically bearish.
That moves us into the 10th April, I believe.
Nope.
11th April.
There's no confirmation.
It's a bunch of respect.
Then New York is approaching highs.
There's a shift.
Chewtail of April, no news.
Nothing.
It's got to be a structural shift, now.
Nothing for our session.
Okay.
So, April, starting off with a little bit of drawdown, as well, to be honest
with you.
Another one.
Not great win rate so far for 2023 with this specific model.
It's not super clean, but it's not a big deal.
It's not a big deal.
Okay.
I don't like that at all, but let's play the model.
This is once said 12 to have news.
Well, inflation rate.
Not a fan of that liquidity at all.
My stop loss is in such a horrible place.
Extremely high chance that price is going to run the highs.
Well, I think so.
But again, this is completely unrefined in a lot of ways.
There's so many ways that I can personally make this model better.
Maybe you can also go away and make this model better for yourself.
Tug.
Technica can't go to break even, but this is a difficult one because I see zero
purpose.
For price coming back to this level, this is maybe something I'll incorporate
as well.
I think it's a difficult one.
I'll take it for now, but from my perspective, I can already see that if I
would like to
take risk off, like that, at least reducing down to 0.3% risk, because the
reality is,
is if price takes this high, there's no way it's holding this high.
It's just not sometimes, yeah, but like maybe one in 50.
Like now I should 100% be at break even.
100%.
But I can't technically.
Like, okay, we'll breach it now.
Now you'll see.
There's no way price is going to trade lower.
Well, I can't do that.
Inflation rates, inflation rates, obviously I can't hold through that.
I'm going to go to break even.
In the live market, I would probably close because we are so close to break
even.
But I shouldn't get any slippage.
We will see.
75, 74.
Yeah, no slippage.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay.
We're approaching the midway point of April and so far we are 5% drawdown or
something.
So we are not off to a great start.
We've just shifted bearish with a very unpleasant price look.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Now I'm probably not going to trade that.
Next day, swing low.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Say.
So that's the same level.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So we are technically, technically bullish.
Yeah, so we're technically bullish right now, which means that we can't short
this.
Unless we trade higher.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
It's more like it.
Go from 1% risk to 0.2% risk.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And we are back in the game.
The same with this model as well, obviously we already discussed this earlier,
but it can be psychologically pressuring.
But that's why you have to understand your edge.
Some people has an edge where every edge has its psychological implications.
Some people who make me have a really high win rate edge.
The average risk reward isn't great, so they might win a few trades and then
lose a few trades.
But after winning a few trades and then losing a few trades, they might be a
drawdown.
They might give all their profit back.
If we win a few trades in a row and then lose a few trades, we don't do that
very, very unlikely.
If you start your week up, if you start your month off with free winners, for
example, that month's going to be profitable.
Very, very highly likely that month's going to be profitable.
You could stop trading at that if you really wanted to.
Those are a little nuances as well.
That you can look at from data.
They will tell you everything, but you just need a large sample size.
I personally don't believe that 50 trades is enough of a sample size to prove
an edge.
Unless there was 50 trades of space over like three years of data because you
're a swing trader.
I think the more, the more the better on the data.
But all ladies are going to have psychological implications.
So just know your age and then just have a level of self-awareness to
understand that like, look, I'm trading an edge that has these type of
implications.
And so when they occur, it's like, this is my edge, like this is what I trade,
this is normal.
It's not like, oh, I'm like a five, six trades losing streak.
Like again, I know it can be difficult.
We're 17 days into the month.
And, you know, we were in drawdown the entire half of the month.
But like I said, one trade back in profit.
18th, excuse me, 18th, we have no bad news.
No full-arm respect of water flow.
So I confirmation some point.
See New York session, we have news in New York where.
We have building permits.
Not a huge deal for me, but I want to see those, I want to see that bi-side
liquidated.
I would have liked to have seen this bi-side liquidated.
This is a sad part because I don't think that that age session is going to get
liquidated now.
But I still can't trade without the liquidation.
And that is the 20th.
Just call yourself though.
That's technically a bullish candle.
But, well, technically neutral is a bullish candle.
So, we're technically bullish, which is really annoying.
Unless we can take that low, which we cannot.
And that's what the session done.
New York.
20th.
No news apparently.
Building up a lot of bi-side liquidated in here.
Oh, there's a name.
Nope.
And I wouldn't trade that.
Oh, that's session done.
Nope.
21st.
Same again.
Nope.
That's all that liquidity taken now, which is nice.
Still respecting structure.
Which is nice.
There's no entry in there.
That takes us to 24th, which we have IFO.
Again, we're still at these highs.
They're probably going to be taken out.
That takes us bullish, which means nothing.
25th of April.
Really low win rate so far for April.
But we may be, like I said, maybe able to improve the win rate using a filter.
Are you kidding me?
I'm tired of these humongous trade managers.
This was the year that I created a three kind of pullback rule if I'm not
mistaken.
20-3.
I think so.
Now I can understand my probably line of thinking and doing so.
25th.
No news.
I think we have a reversal here.
Tableauk.
Oh yeah, of course, we can't know.
Yeah, I think I recall.
They're being such like small stop sizes and stuff.
Surely because I was refining everything.
Trying to get the perfect order block.
I think we're going to be able to improve the quality of the market.
Okay.
26.
Now that we can do about it, that's really frustrating.
Yeah, but we're so bullish.
Okay, the next two days are crazy for news.
We're looking for longs.
GDP.
Now.
So you don't trade news.
28th, 28th is also a loaded day.
And that's also the final day of.
There's a crazy loaded day for Euro.
Yeah, and then New York, we're not going to get anything because.
That is all news.
Nope.
And that is April.
Terrible, terrible April.
Look at our day.
So we're dealing with a 25% win rate.
Still a bit average winter loss ratio, but obviously it's still profitable at
the end of the day.
It's 12% in three months, which is still a decent return.
It's more so the inconsistency and the market conditions, of course.